dear friend
vice president biden
who i have always
admired and respected and
both the president and i have learned an
awful lot from the vice president over
the years thank you
and i want to thank
the deputy secretary of defense who is
here bob work
and the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general marty dempsey
who also is here
i want to thank them
for being here
this morning
i
also want to thank
you both for your tremendous leadership
of the defense department and what you
mean to our men and women and their
families all over the world and for the
honor i've had to serve
with each of you
and the privilege it's it's been in
every way and i want to thank the
entire leadership team at the pentagon
without their support and wise counsel
over the last couple of years
our many accomplishments and the
president noted some
i have been
part of that
but it's a team
it's all these tremendous men and women
as you know mr president that make this
happen and i couldn't be prouder of them
and what we have accomplished over the
almost two years that i've had the honor
of serving in this position
and as the president noted i have today
submitted my resignation of secretary of
defense